[Music]
Sudan's warring parties have accused
each other of violating a fragile
ceasefire which has now been extended
for three more days hundreds of people
have been killed in a violent power
struggle between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support Force the UN
is sending its chief of Aid as an Envoy
to Sudan Martin Griffith says
humanitarian situation there is now
reaching Breaking Point Hippa Morgan
reports from khatu
Nigerian students Run for Cover in
Khartoum
like millions of others they've been
trapped in the city for more than two
weeks the United Nations is warning
Sudan is falling apart as the Army and
the paramilitary group the rapid support
forces battle for control there are
shortages of food water fuel and
Medicine
the interior Ministry has deployed extra
police officers in Khartoum to stop
looting but what people really want is a
permanent ceasefire so far several
foreign mediated truths have barely held
the announcement of a new three-day
ceasefire hasn't generated much optimism
among people here in hartum many say the
ceasefire means little as they continue
to witness daily fighting and remain cut
off from many of their basic needs
foreign
North to the city of umdurman both are
under heavy bombardment as is the area
around the presidential Palace and Army
headquarters
every day thousands of people decide
it's no longer safe to stay
this rescue ship in Port Sudan is taking
evacuees to Saudi Arabia around 5 000
syrians say they're being processed more
slowly than other nationalities
we've been here for eight days the
evacuation of syrians has stopped the
day before yesterday only 27 people were
evacuated no syrians were evacuated
yesterday we do not know what is
happening and no one gives us a clear
answer
in arguin on the Egypt Sudan border
satellite images share Cruise of buses
waiting to take people across others
have flown home on the first two days of
the war it was action in Port sedan with
a couple of jets flying over and some
bombs Landing but in ports then itself
it was quiet so a lot but obviously a
lot of military action but no fighting
but everyone's teens everyone but but
even the Sudanese people we work with
wanted to go back to normal because they
just want their country to to grow and
prosper
former prime minister Abdullah has added
his voice to those calling for an end to
the conflict
warning it could deteriorate into one of
the worst civil wars in the world Hiba
Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum
Abdul Rahman babica is a Sudanese
physicist physician who was stranded in
Khartoum but managed to return to the
United Kingdom he explains the harrowing
Journey Back
you can hear the fire shot around you
you can see the airplane above you you
can see the smokes from the bombs and
all things it's really scary point to go
to see if you can be evacuated or not
and then you will go through many
checkpoints to be seen uh which is
sometimes a bit scary if especially if
you are thinking that you will go
through the rabbit support uh forces
because sometimes they will threaten the
people and uh they may harm them uh so
it's really difficult uh have been
really treated well with the military
the national uh military people uh
soliders that they are checking in the
way till the till the airport two days
before just I went there there was a
bomb in one of the medical center just
two blocks from us we heard it on 14
people got injured in there uh two of
them have amputation of their hands and
many got bleeding and then they brought
to the nearby hospital in which they are
there are no medical staff because no
one can reach to the hospital also there
is no Medical Aid so I'm really worried
about it about them especially my dad
and mom if they got ill at any time how
can they receive any support from the
hospital or even how can they reach the
hospital to have some treatment it's
it's really worrying thingy I I made it
but they didn't made it they are still
in there they don't know what to do
exactly so it's bit of scary uh it's not
a bit of scale it's really scary and
it's really worrying actually
David Shin is the former deputy chief of
mission at the U.S embassy in Sudan he
says there's no room for governments to
pick sides in this conflict
the vast majority of it is an internal
issue it really is a power struggle
between the Sudan Armed Forces on the
one hand and the rapid support forces on
the other
there is some external involvement
historically because of financial
support
or in just plain moral support for one
side or the other the degree to which
that is happening today is unclear I
think that anyone on the outside who was
supporting one side or the other before
this broke out will want to rethink
their their policy on this because all
it would do at this point is to
contribute to a continuation of the
conflict in almost all outside countries
agree that is not in their interest they
can ensure that they don't provide any
financial assistance to any of the
contending parties they can also look at
way is to put Financial pressure
on the contending parties based on
whatever foreign direct investment they
have in the country or whatever other
Financial connections they might have in
order to try to get them to draw back
from the ongoing fighting and that
applies to other countries too not not
just the the Gulf States but many
countries have a financial investment in
Sudan today
evacuation flights from Sudan have
started arriving in neighboring South
Sudan's capital haramatasa met some of
the evacuees in Juba who say they
traveled for days before finding a
flight home
there are at least three flights like
this every day and they're being
sponsored by local businessmen who say
the service is free people don't have to
pay all they have to do is take it from
Sudan to South Sudan's border and then
walk to an airstrip that's nearby and
then flown here to Juba South Sudan's
capital we asked some of them what the
journey was like from Sudan and they
said that more people are still coming
and it's mainly women the elderly and
children it's a villain are really
suffering there are no Foods there are
no water people are dying there is a
certain lady who died because of
diabetes they are there are no medical
care the bad thing the bad thing I see
is that room the fighting with breakout
within the city yeah even children were
being killed the International Community
is trying to resolve the conflict in
Sudan here in South Sudan politicians
are trying to organize face-to-face
meetings routine representatives from
the Sudanese Army and the paramilitary
rsf but getting the two sides to sit
down together may take time
148 somalis have arrived in the capital
Mogadishu the evacuees mostly students
travel from Sudan to Ethiopia by land
and then took a flight home the airline
lift was organized by somalia's
government and the International
Organization for migration
many people in Sudan who had submitted
travel documents to foreign embassies
are still stranded that's after several
countries evacuated their diplomats
rahili Muhammad reports
some Sudanese say they are trapped in
Khartoum without their passports tens of
thousands of people are fleeing to
neighboring countries dozens of foreign
governments have flown out their
citizens and diplomatic staff but for
some Sudanese leaving is not an option
as their travel documents are locked in
shuttered embassies
while we spoke to Sudanese residents
still stuck in the capital after failing
to retrieve their passports
by the end of March I have applied for a
study visa to South Africa and by the
day of 18th of April after three days
before starting most of diplomats and
different emphasis staff were evacuated
so I couldn't reach my passport so I
can't go anywhere
I didn't get any response from the
embassy no announcement no phone calls
even no direct messages I applied for
the Schengen visa at the Swedish Embassy
in Horton I didn't get my passport back
because they the staff simply up and
left with complete disregard to the
situation uh it's not just either 100 of
us in different EU embassies it's
utterly irresponsible and and it's such
a shame because they have they spend a
lot of money on on Curbing the
migrations illegal migration when they
can't even come up with an EB the system
so situations like this do not happen I
am in the Spanish Embassy multiple times
and I called them multiple times but
when they found out I was in Spanish
they hung up without any explanation me
and my family Force deliver houses it
was no longer safe my family scattered
me and my brother came to Port Sudan but
he couldn't defeated my mother and
sister are currently in the Egyptian
border trying to cross through Egypt and
I'm here not knowing what I will be
doing next
imagine a lot of people are trying to
figure out what happening with their pay
protecting governments on Twitter the
the Dutch foreign Ministry recently
replied to a Visa query confirming that
a number of Sudanese passports had been
left behind at the embassy it advises
people to apply for a new passport with
local authorities another criticism of
foreign governments is automated
responses dozens of people are sharing
their frustrations online as well now
some countries are trying to work around
those changes on the ground the Swiss
Embassy says it's working hard to find
options for people to collect their
passports and the Chinese Embassy says
Sudanese residents can now collect their
documents in Khartoum now with so many
people in limbo you may be wondering
what are the legal implications Sudan
has signed a number of treaties
including the international Covenant on
civil and political rights it states
everyone lawfully within the territory
of the state shall within that territory
have the right to Liberty of movement
and everyone shall be free to leave any
country including his own rights groups
say governments can be held liable for
not doing enough to return passports to
Visa applicants